>> Hannity: ARE READY TO ROLL
BUT I'M WORRIED ABOUT MONKEYPOX
NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
AND WELCOME TO "HANNITY" THE
JOE BIDEN A ADMINISTRATION IS IN
A FREE FALL AND I MEAN LITERALLY
AS IT TURNS OUT EVEN LONG
WEEKENDS AT THE BEACH ARE A
STRUGGLE FOR PORT JOEY ON
SATURDAY AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW BY
NOW THE PRESIDENT FELL YET AGAIN
THIS TIME HE WAS UNABLE TO
MAINTAIN HIS BALANCE AFTER A
LEISURELY TAKING A BIKE RIDE IN
DELAWARE WITH THE FIRST LADY
THANKFULLY WITH SOME HELP AT
SOME NICE PEOPLE AROUND HIM HE
WAS ABLE TO GET BACK ON HIS FEET
NOW HE IS OKAY.
THIS COMES AMID GROWING CONCERNS
FROM THE DEMOCRATS ON THE LEFT
THAT EVEN "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S MENTAL AND
PHYSICAL FITNESS NOW EVEN SOME
DEMOCRATS ARE QUESTIONING
JOE BIDEN'S ABILITIES AND
CASTING DOUBT ON A SECOND TERM
WHICH HE SAYS HE IS GONNA RUN
FOR OF COURSE THE WHITE HOUSE AS
WELL AWARE OF THESE CONCERNS AND
THIS WEEKEND IN ORDER TO
REASSURE YOU THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
THAT THEY HAD THE PRESIDENT FROM
A VARIETY OF FRANKLY
EMBARRASSING POLITICAL PHYSICAL
ACTS IN OTHER WORDS THEY PUT ON
A SHOW.
ULTIMATELY THEY DO MORE HARM
THAN GOOD.
ON FRIDAY JOE BIDEN DID HIS VERY
BEST SCRIPTING ALL WAY BACK
GOOD JOB JOE.
HE SET IT UP A COMPETITIVE
CYCLIST FELL OFF HIS BICYCLE
WHEN HE CAME TO A STOP ON SUNDAY
HE PRETENDED TO JUMP ROPE FOR
THE CAMERAS I WAS KIND OF SAD
AND DEEPLY CONCERNED THERE IS
JUMP AND RUB GOOD JOB JOE
79-YEAR-OLD PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
PRETTY MUCH UNABLE TO STAY
UPRIGHT AND REMEMBER THIS
PARTICULAR INCIDENT THE
WHITE HOUSE THEY BLAME THE FIRST
MAJOR FALL OR FRUIT THREE FALSE
IT WAS VERY WINDY DAY I KNOW
WHAT'S WORSE THE FACT THAT HE
FELT THREE TIMES OR THE FIGHT
FOR LYING TO US AND SAID IT WAS
WINDY DAY THAT'S PROBABLY WHY HE
FELL THE SAME WEEK THAT THE WIND
IS BLOWING THEM OVER IT'S NOT
EXACTLY HURRICANE OVER THERE
ANYWAY BUT AS OF THIS HOUR WE
HAVE NOT HEARD IF THEY ARE
CLAIMING WIND UP LOOM ON HIS
BICYCLE BUT THEY SUGGESTED FOR
THE REASON THAT HE TRIPPED GOING
UP THE STAIRS AND AIR FORCE ONE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DID THE PRESIDENT TO GUFFAW
ON THE STAIRS IS HE OKAY?
>> AS YOU KNOW IT'S PRETTY WINDY
OUTSIDE VERY WINDY I WILL SPELL
COMING UP THE STAIRS MYSELF.
HE IS DOING A HUNDRED PERCENT
FINE.
>> Hannity: IT'S 20 I COULD
BARELY KEEP UP THE NEW
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
SAYS.
OKAY THIS TIME THEY'RE CHANGING
THEIR TUNE UP A LITTLE BIT THE
WHITE HOUSE IS BLAMING THE BIKE
AND NATURALLY THE MEDIA MOB IS
TOTALLY OF CONCERN AND MORE THAN
HAPPY TO LOOK THE OTHER WAY AND
THAT BARELY REPORTING ON
JOE BIDEN'S FALL AT ALL.
REMEMBER TWO YEARS AGO WHEN
THEN-PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP
CAREFULLY WALKED DOWN A WET RAMP
THAT DIDN'T HAVE ANY GUARDRAILS
ALL IN SLICK DRESS SHOES YOU
KNOW KIND OF DANGEROUS EVER
TRIED IT NOT GOOD.
ANYWAY HE WENT DOWN SLOWLY THE
MEDIA MOB WENT BALLISTIC.
ALBERT ACCUSED HIM OF HAVING
NEUROLOGICAL DISORDER OF SOME
KIND.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF AS
HAVING MOMENTARY STUMBLES
MATERIAL LAPSES STRAIGHTFORWARD
WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE.
SPENDING TIME IS WE CAN GET AWAY
THEIR LIKES GET OUT SOMETIMES
TOGGLE PEOPLE PERHAPS THIS IS
NOT THE INTERACTION HE WAS
PLANNING HOPING FOR TODAY.
HE TOOK A LITTLE BIT OF A TUMBLE
WHILE BIKING BUT I WAS DOING
REALLY?
>> MAYBE HE JUST HAS A HARD TIME
GOING OUT A GENTLY SLOPING RAMP
BUT DO YOU SEE SOMETHING
POSSIBLY NEUROLOGICALLY THEY
COULD BE TURNED OFF HIS BALANCE?
>> PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN FELL OFF
OF HIS BIKE IN FRONT OF A CROWD
AND THE PRESS DELAWARE THE
PRESIDENT SAID THAT THE CAGES ON
HIS BIKE GOT CAUGHT AND THAT
MADE HIM FALL SIDEWAYS.
HE IS A OKAY IS NO PHYSICAL
SCRIPTURE BRUISES FROM THE FALL.
>> JOE BIDEN IS FIGHTING BACK AT
A WEST POINT COMMENCEMENT
EARLIER THIS YEAR.
>> LOOK HOW HE STEPPED IN HOW I
STEPPED.
[LAUGHS]
LOOK HE STUMBLES DOWN RIGHT
THERE.
COME ON.
>> Hannity: THEY MOBBED
JOE BIDEN AND THEIR TITLE
ADMINISTRATION BUT NOT JUST HIS
MENTAL AND PHYSICAL STAMINA
THERE ALSO AND DENIAL OF THE
CRISIS ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER
THERE AND DENIAL ABOUT VIOLENT
CRIME IN AMERICAN CITIES DURING
DENIAL ABOUT INFLATION YOUR
HIGH.
THE HIGHEST GAS PRICES WE
COVERED EXPERIENCE SIX BUCKS A
GALLON AND DENIAL ABOUT THE
LOOMING RECESSION AS A RESULT OF
HIS ECONOMIC AND ENERGY POLICIES
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT SEEMS MORE LIKELY THAN
EVER.
>> President Biden: COME ON
DON'T MAKE THIS UP.
THEY ARE SOUNDING LIKE A
REPUBLICAN POLITICIAN, I'M
JOKING.
NO I DON'T THINK IT IS.
>> Hannity: ACCORDING TO THE
ECONOMIC MODELS AND THE
ECONOMIST AND FORMER OBAMA
ADVISED LARRY SUMMERS THIS
COUNTRY IS ALL BUT CERTAIN TO
FALL INTO A RECESSION BY 2024,
JOE BIDEN AND THE ENTIRE
ADMINISTRATION ARE IN DENIAL
THROUGH ITS SAME THING WITH GAS
PRICES TAKE A LOOK.
>> President Biden: THE IDEA
THAT WERE TO BE ABLE TO FLICK A
SWITCH AND BREAK DOWN THE COST
OF GASOLINE IS NOT LIKELY IN THE
NEAR TERM.
>> THE PRESIDENT SAID AND MADE
VERY CLEAR THAT IS NOT MUCH LEFT
THAT HE CAN DO.
>> UNFORTUNATELY THAT IS A
BRUTAL REALITY THE REALITY IS
THAT THERE ISN'T VERY MUCH MORE
TO BE DONE.
>> WITH RESPECT TO ENERGY IN THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THING THAT
THEY CAN TO BRING DOWN ENERGY
COSTS.
>> Hannity: THIS IS WHERE I
GET REALLY ANGRY WE HAVE DONE
EVERYTHING CAMPUS NOT MUCH ELSE
WE CAN DO IT ARTIFICIALLY REDUCE
THE WORLD SUPPLY YOU DON'T GO TO
HARVARD BUSINESS SCHOOL OR MIT
OR AN IVY LEAGUE SCHOOL TO
FIGURE OUT SUPPLY AND DEMAND
THEY CRISSCROSS AND THEY DICTATE
THE PRICE AND THAT KINDER SCREEN
REDUCE THE WORLD SUPPLY OF OIL
AND GAS AND THE PRICE IS GONE UP
DRAMATICALLY AND NOW HE'S ABOUT
TO KISS THE OF THE CROWN
PRINCE OF THAT NATION CALLED
SAUDI ARABIA THE NATION IS YOU
CALL IT THE GUY THAT HE ACCUSED
OF KILLING JOURNALISTS
JAMAL KHASHOGGI ABOUT THE SUCK
UP TO HIM LIKE THEY'RE SUCKING
UP TO VENEZUELA LIKE THEY'RE
SUCKING UP TO A RAN BECAUSE OF
THIS CLIMATE OF THE LARGEST
RELIGIOUS CULT WILL NONE OF THIS
IS GONNA HAPPEN ALL OF THIS
COULD'VE BEEN PREVENTABLE AND
IT'S ALL FIXABLE.
IF YOU SAID WE JUST RESTART THE
KEYSTONE XL PIPELINE WILL GET
900,000 BARRELS OF CANADIAN OIL
A DAY START THERE.
THEY CAN LIFT THE DRILLING BAN
WE PRETTY MUCH UNLIMITED
SUPPLIES THERE AND OTHER FEDERAL
LANDS LICENSE PERMITS TO THE OIL
COMPANIES THEY CAN LIFT
RESTRICTIONS OFF FRACKING AND
REFINERIES BUT INSTEAD OF TAKING
THOSE PRODUCTIVE STEPS TO RAMP
UP DOMESTIC PRODUCTION OF OIL
AND GAS ACT LIKE WILL THEY THROW
UP THEIR HANDS LIKE WE'VE DONE
EVERYTHING WE CAN.
A SMALL TOWN TURN TRANSPORTATION
SECRETARY IN OVER HIS HEAD
PETE BUTTIGIEG TRUSTS
PRESS SECRETARY OUT TO LUNCH
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT SOME SWITCH
TO RENEWABLES.
ONCE WE ARE ENERGY INDEPENDENT
WITH HER NOBLES WILL BE ABLE TO
GET LOWER PRICES ON ENERGY.
WHAT RENEWABLES?
EXACTLY EXPLAIN WHAT TECHNOLOGY
THERE TALK ABOUT WHERE ARE THEY?
WHEN WILL THEY COME ONLINE?
WHAT IS THE PLAN HERE AND CAN
ANYONE IN THE ADMINISTRATION
ANSWER ANY OF THESE QUESTIONS?
IF IT'S RENEWABLE SO GREAT WHY
IS JOE BIDEN HEADING TO
SAUDI ARABIA THE PARIAH NATION
AS HE CALLS IT TO KISS THE OF
CROWN PRINCE WHO HE ACCUSED OF
MURDER THEY CAME TO PUMP MORE
OIL?
WHEN I JUST GO TO MIDLAND,
TEXAS, GO TO NORTH DAKOTA, GET
THE NATURAL GAS IN PENNSYLVANIA
AND CREATE HIGH-PAYING CAREER
JOBS AND NOT HAVE TO PUT THE
LIFEBLOOD OF OUR ECONOMY IN THE
HANDS OF PEOPLE MANY OF WHOM DO
NOT LIKE US I DON'T LIKE THAT
GUY AND I DON'T TRUST THAT GUY.
NOR SHOULD WE.
SAUDI ARABIA, OPEC NATIONS,
VENEZUELA, A RAN THEY ALL PRETTY
MUCH HATE US.
SADLY WE ARE NOW BEING LED BY
COMPLETE TOTAL FOOLS AND IN OUR
TRANSPORTATION SECRETARY FORMER
MAYOR OF INDIANA DOES NOBODY'S
DOING THE ENERGY SECRETARY IS A
SELF-PROCLAIMED
ENVIRONMENTALISTS WHO HATES THE
OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY A YEAR AGO
THE TREASURY SECRETARY TOLD THEM
THAT INFLATION WAS TRANSITORY IN
THIS COUNTRY SPIRALING INTO A
HORRIBLE RECORD HIGH INFLATION
RECORD HIGH GAS PRICES AND GET
READY FOR THE ROLLING THAT'S ON
THE WAY ALONG WITH THE PRESIDENT
WAS UNABLE AND UNWILLING TO WORK
HARD OR ANSWER QUESTIONS OR SIT
DOWN FOR INTERVIEWS GIVE PRETTY
MUCH ANYTHING OF VALUES TAKE A
LOOK.
>> TO STOMACH I CAN'T TALK TO
YOU ON MY VACATION.
>> Hannity: I WILL NOT TALK TO
YOU I'M ON VACATION UP FALLING
BICYCLE.
TO BE ON US OUR COUNTRY WILL
PROBABLY BE BE BETTER OFF IF HE
STAYED ON VACATION ANYWAY LET'S
FIND SOMEONE ELSE MORE CAPABLE
ALTHOUGH COPPOLA GIGGLING
VICE PRESIDENT DOESN'T INSPIRE
CONFIDENCE NANCY PELOSI HAS HER
OWN KINDNESSES STRUGGLE ON TAKE
A LOOK.
IT'S CLEAR THAT THE TRUE
PROBLEMS OF OUR NATION A MUCH
DEEPER DEEPER THAN GASOLINE
LINES ARE ENERGY SHORTAGES.
DEEPER THAN AN INFLATION OR
RECESSION.
AFTER LISTENING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE I'VE BEEN REMINDED AGAIN
THAT ALL THE LEGISLATION O